you want to go first
you go it just takes a village to make
the gray man the grey man is set to
surpass any expectations you may have
with nine intense action sequences a
stacked cast and a ridiculous budget the
russo brothers are shooting to create a
new action franchise ready to find out
just how they brought it all together
number one joe compared this situation
to a monty python skit there was a car
on a swivel in front of a green screen
and the russos told ryan to lay down and
just hang on as if the car was spinning
at a very high speed all they had to do
was shake it a bit it wasn't going the
way joe hoped so he climbed on the car
to show gosling how it's done hopefully
we get to see the secret take they
filmed
number two gosling went through all the
different martial arts styles i've never
made an action movie before so it's it
was a lot for me of course the movie is
designed around him so it was all on his
shoulders seven months were devoted to
intense highly specialized choreography
the russos were a couple of teases to
gosling too they were eating like kings
while he was eating some quote dried
chicken breast thing
joe's never met anyone who could do
stunts like chris evans at least until
gosling
number three you should always be
cautious of what they save for the end
of filming take ryan gosling's word for
it he said when i was on the tram it was
nearly the end of filming i'm running on
top of these tram cars and they're
falling beneath my feet as i jump i
remember thinking this sums up this
experience this is exactly what this
movie has felt like number four despite
the nine action sequences the cast went
pretty unscathed it was like a knock
down drag out every day kind of thing
but no emotional scars joe russo said
that gosling was getting beat up
sequence after sequence and was weirdly
loving it while chris evans got into a
little tussle with the grey man and
battered his arm pretty bad deiobia
operae trained for four months for a 10
minute sequence i was like oh pain or
your back oh no baby okay have fun
number five watch out for her the
training was
really like 360 training anna said you
have to create this unity on set and you
have to match the other person's energy
and you need to be very careful and give
the other person the space to also feel
safe and go at their own speed she's
she's dangerous she's a dangerous person
be careful number six keep in mind the
average is four nine action sequences is
just insane the idea was to create a
relentless experience for the audience
joe and anthony are entertained by xf
the novel the movie is based on has 11
action sequences
joe had no idea how they were going to
fit it all into one film but they
managed to pair it down to nine number
seven chris ran mustache first into this
part so said ryan gosling while evans
character manifests as a sociopath he
doesn't see it that way he sees him as
someone fearless being his authentic
self chris believes that usually
villains aren't burdened by complexities
and insecurities number eight this movie
had barely any deleted scenes maybe a
line was cut here or there but these
guys were on a tight ship the russos
have a very disciplined approach to
working on a script they're more than
willing to cut things before they get
filmed rather than do all that work and
cut it later because energy is precious
number nine from greyscale to a rainbow
of awesomeness they wanted an
extravagant amount of color to contrast
the lead character joe said the way that
we approached the look and feel of the
movie was in contrast to the expectation
they played with different techniques to
keep the lead out of focus by putting
him in a weird part of the frame
lighting him slightly less or keeping
the focus off of him which anthony said
sort of created the idea of a ghost-like
quality number 10 the whole cast was put
through the ringer okay i've worked for
these x amount of months let's see what
we got joe admitted it's extremely
physical it can be painful there's a
cirque du soleil level of choreography
going on people are throwing punches at
each other at very high speed and if
somebody misses by an inch someone has a
broken jaw it requires incredible
precision and a lot of training
number eleven the russos are giving us a
slightly different kind of action star
joe said he's a very modern hero he's
existential he's obsessed with sisyphus
the greek myth of this character stuck
in futility it's what separates him from
bond and born as ryan said it's a
proletariat hero he just wants to get
the job done and go home and he has no
desire to romanticize it number 12.
despite your best efforts sometimes you
have to make a cut filming the hospital
scene took weeks before they'll release
the actors for the day they watch the
footage to make sure it's working and if
it isn't they get back to work they
tried a ton of different ideas on this
one it's the only one where any real
cuts happened because they were so
experimental with it
i mean i could see that
number 13. their process is almost like
cheating surround yourself with good
people and you only have to do half the
work the other half of the work is great
communication anna found she had freedom
to explore during rehearsal times find
out what she was and wasn't comfortable
with and then they built the fight
scenes around her and her ability number
14 we're not talking about the hissing
cobra chicken's devil spawn still just
ryan gosling got the call when the
pandemic hit about some globe-trotting
epic blockbuster for netflix he didn't
think it was serious but reality hit
when he got his call time he always
wanted to make an action film it took a
long time to find the right one but he
knew that this was it because the russos
were manning the helm
number 15. the russo brothers have been
obsessed with ryan for the last two
decades just like everybody else his
character craves an anonymity but when
he talks the character has to be quirky
and funny joe finds it hard to find an
actor who possesses ryan's range because
ryan's incredible with minimalism able
to convey an entire interior life with
just a few looks number 16. keep in mind
john wick only cost 25 million to make
this is netflix's most expensive film
ever costing 200 million dollars this
partially had to do with all of the
cities that made gorgeous backdrops for
the film including chateau de shanti in
france los angeles the czech republic
thailand austria and azerbaijan we shot
an awful lot of it in a hangar in long
beach between the locations and the nine
action sequences that take up three
quarters of the film they really racked
up the bill number 17. dynamic
characters is the name of the casting
game joe called anna a badass who can
embody her character in an extremely
truthful way anthony said she had to
create a very rich in her life where we
can follow her thoughts and we can see
her calculating her way through
challenges number 18. so the stunt
coordinator has an excellent sense of
fashion of course they have a martial
arts school in orange county and that's
their tracksuit number 19. let's just
say the russos could have used 48 hours
in a day the movie almost did in the two
of them they were so tired by the end of
it because action requires an intense
level of thought care and execution on
set but of course the action wasn't
their only responsibility they were also
editing at night and recrafting
constantly so they weren't sleeping
number 20 here's hoping this is the end
of these pandemic tales of woe huh
jessica just like kind of possibly notes
under the floor saying hey can we be
friends there was a lot of ad-hoc
building of environments due to the
pandemic and i'd send back a little note
full of heart saying no the grey man is
shaping up to be the action movie of the
year and for good reason huh do you
think there's a point where an action
movie can have too much action let us
know your thoughts in the comments and
thanks for hanging out with us here at
the things